[Music]
house minority leader kevin mccarthy is
already laying out an america first
agenda for a republican majority if they
win the house in november this will be
the most important midterm in our
lifetime first mccarthy says he will
remove far-left extremists like adam
schiff you know the single congenital
liar that he is the single biggest
purveyor of election lies in the history
of this country and his fellow russia
hoaxer eric swalwell off the house intel
committee as well as congresswoman omar
from the house foreign affairs committee
and that's not all mccarthy is also
vowing to move forward on legislation
that could include an outright ban on
lawmakers trading stocks while in office
amid a new report about the questionable
investing behavior of dozens of members
of congress yep including speaker nancy
pelosi here to explain house minority
leader kevin mccarthy kevin let me let
me start with this question
if you become speaker of the house
next year this time next year
will you pledge to have a real january 6
committee we know that donald trump as
required by law authorized to calling up
20 000 guardsmen he did it in front of
the chairman of the joint chiefs the
secretary of defense the chief of staff
and the defense department chief of
staff
will you pledge
that if you become speaker
that you will subpoena nancy pelosi
muriel bowser who refused to follow up
it was their chain of command they had
to call them up after the president
approved it the sergeant-at-arms and the
d.c police chief and will you subpoena
their tax phone calls and emails if you
become speaker
the first thing we're going to do we've
already asked to preserve all those
records the answer could be very clear
why did the democrats when they created
january 6
pick and choose which republicans could
be on disallowing never before in
history individuals that i selected as
minority leader why did the chair of
this committee say the speaker is off
limits why did the speaker not allow the
information from the sergeant of arms
that communication with the speaker
there's two main questions you want on
january 6. why was the capital so
ill-prepared that day and how do we make
sure it never happens again you cannot
answer any of those questions without
getting that communication and we will
get it sean so we can get the answers
the law required donald trump to
uh
allow them to be called up then it
became the jurisdiction of nancy pelosi
and muriel bowser muriel bowser in
writing rejected it nancy pelosi we'd
like to know she won't turn over her
phone records or the sergeant-at-arms so
you're pledging a full real
investigation
for the and for the right reasons we
can't let this ever happen again just
like we can't let the summer riots of
2020 happen again
remember what congressman rodney davis
who sent the letter to preserve all that
communications
long ago he is the ranking member on
house administration he is also when
we've had all the
the reports about the changes that need
to be made to the capitol police he has
offered him but you have a democrat
chair zoe lofgren who stays home and
votes proxy instead of holding any of
the hearings going forward you've got a
chairman of january 6 who says the
speaker is off limits that cannot be the
case we've got to get the answers to
those questions and make sure this
capital is safe uh adam schiff the
biggest purveyor of election lies in
history eric swalwell as you pointed out
can't get a security clearance in the
private sector uh we know all about
congresswoman omar
they will be
taken off committee assignments and you
will put a ban on on people like nancy
pelosi
investing in stocks that they might have
influence on
yeah intel committee is a special
committee only appointed by the leaders
this is where you get the secrets to
america and around the world
adam schiff will go down as one of the
worst chairmans of intel remember what
he did he turned it in to a political
committee here we have afghanistan
collapsing where the president's saying
it's going to be able to sustain itself
we've got bagram collapsing where
prisoners are getting out where they
took one of those individuals that was
in that prison and killed 13 of our
service men and women that made 13 new
gold star families maybe if the intel
committee was focused on what they were
supposed to be focused on instead of
putting out a fake dossier and others we
wouldn't have that situation then you
have swalwell who the fbi warned us that
had
a knowledge of a chinese spy continue to
put on there when eric swalwell goes to
the private sector he was not going to
be approved for security clearance why
would government give him a clearance to
the secrets of america to me it's very
simple we're going to turn the intel
committee
back around to what it's supposed to be
protecting america around the world and
knowing what is happening instead of
just being this political organization
and lo and behold where else is adam
shift he's on the january 6 committee he
should be focusing on protecting this
company and we're going to stop we're
going to bring back faith in congress
the speaker of the house has all the
power she can determine what bill comes
to the floor whether it gets marked up
or not and what does her husband do
he invests not just buying a stock he
buys options he buys options when it
comes to tech companies when we're
debating those bills and only one person
knows whether they're going to pass the
house or even bring him up and he makes
millions of dollars in a month i just
think that's wrong we're going to
respond
and accountability you'll have the
support of of republicans and
conservatives around the country we're
going to hold you to it those are
important issues every one of them thank
you for being with us hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else